I know that there's gonna be some crazy
baby products of the future I know if
there's gonna be a stroller with Wi-Fi
baby use they're just great like they're
so nice to hold you don't know what
you're holding you could be holding like
the next president of the United States
I have two boys they're the best humans
on the planet with my second time they
actually told me he was the girl and
that's kind of all I've ever wanted I
mean don't get me wrong I love my boys
but there's just something about mother
having a daughter I do feel like this
emotional clock ticking where I need
this like little bundle of joy to remind
me that there's good in life and they're
just good dog me and my girlfriend have
talked very briefly about kids I think
it would freak her out to know how much
I actually love kiss beep and like oh
the kid okay yeah
oh she's so cute oh hey hey doing okay a
baby the first one I've ever been able
to make out how weird don't let my
girlfriend see this in my son's one and
I've already forgotten this stage of his
life I think that's why I started crying
right for you you're gonna do awesome
things they can tell it well actual
videos do this
J it was so cute I know I just was like
oh that couldn't be my baby she just had
these beautiful brown eyes it's crazy
how how fast they grow up and oh you
don't even remember it I'm like so happy
well except I don't want a daughter or a
boy I don't even care baby I love baby
hey sweetie do you want to have a
daughter
hi really what kids
I don't experience them for like five
minutes but I think that's enough time
to know that I want to make a lifelong
commitment Parenthood is most
heartbreaking time of your life because
you're so proud and happy and so
crushingly devastated at the same time
that your kids are growing up
though much strength they're so strong